night has fallen over Berlin and while
roaming through the streets I've noticed
a lot of vegan restaurants here in the
city that makes me curious so I've
arranged to meet somebody who should
know all about it at a restaurant called
chips hi any colder places Anya Sonia
right now sir is a nutritionist and food
coach chips is a vegetarian restaurant
with a wide selection of vegan dishes so
it's right in line with the times
masconomet daughter dance onions a lot
of people know what vegetarianism is
about but what exactly does it mean to
lead a vegan lifestyle we began by Isis
as a began wadada dazzle a vegan diet is
plant-based that means completely
abstaining from consuming animal
products including sausage cheese eggs
meat and fish vegans refrain from eating
animal products or buying products that
have been tested on animals that
includes flavor enhancers made from
animal products so when you're buying
food items you've really got to take a
look at the list of ingredients does
clink ethnic menu sounds quite
complicated why do you think that more
and more people are nonetheless opting
for a vegan diet dinka anisette I think
it's partly due to media coverage about
how animals are raised and how food
products are made does people are asking
whether some kinds of food are really
good for us and we've seen new diseases
and allergies cropping up my people who
are concerned about these things a vegan
diet offers an excellent alternative
that's a crappy stage we can say a man
why do you think this trend is
especially pronounced in large cities as
I think that's elaeis big cities are
very pluralistic there's a lot going on
and there's a multi cultural influence
you can see that clearly in Berlin which
is Germany's vegan capital there are a
lot of different influences here a lot
of visionary people it's also home to a
lot of startups because we're keen to
try new things and I also think there's
more awareness here in Berlin who are
getting million
beta argument what do you say to people
who consider vegan cuisine boring is so
I'm to me consciousness Agra I'd say
they haven't really tried it I use lots
of different vegetables and herbs I find
different varieties of the organic
market quiet nvidia music vegan food is
really more creative and diverse than
you might think teva feel buncha on feel
effects and spider me big on how popular
is it with Berlin star chefs has it
caught on with them I think is this guns
clap Susie we've seen a clear trend
recently you can find vegan dishes on
any menu even the finest restaurants
more and more people are trying vegan
food and asking for it in restaurants
and the chefs are working to meet that
demand feeling thanks for talking to us
whether it's vegan or standard cuisine
Berlin is one of Germany's gourmet
capitals one of the city's top chefs is
Daniel Achilles he and his restaurant
anged off consistently received top
marks from European food critics
but Achilles isn't the only chef in
Berlin who's won international acclaim
the German capital has made it to the
first division when it comes to fine
dining miss antwine managing Berlin is a
real melting pot of cuisine and
contemporary cooking the chef's
continually watch the trends developing
around the world and of course they look
at what the guest wants and can enjoy
not so long ago eating out in Berlin was
a hit or miss affair the city was
primarily known for curry Wurst & doner
kebab Berlin rarely featured on gourmets
maps the Berlin Wall limited resources
for chefs in the former West getting
fresh and regional food was nearly
impossible in communist East Berlin
meanwhile top-notch restaurants were
basically non-existent not even hotels
catering to foreign diplomats could
offer gourmet food the city was
transformed after the fall of the wall
and had to rediscover itself all over
that provided plenty of room for young
chefs and new ideas and for
international cuisine and experiments
mentor it all began in 2000 with the
opening of Margo chef Michele Hoffman
has been setting new standards here for
14 years after him more chefs followed
Christian loser has been wowing diners
at fish's Fritz since 2004
hendrik auto at the lohans ad lon has
two Michelin stars and now 18 points in
a new gourmet or for all these top chefs
Berlin is a source of inspiration it's
called assistance punster it's the
liveliest and most exciting culinary
scene anywhere hope cuddle in the
mid-range segment that's evolved in
Berlin just below a one-star rating
there's a lot of really interesting
development forum stem cooked the
synthesis and that's what makes Berlin
special would gain the concept it when
does estas verse billion Ozma the most
innovative among Berlin's top chefs is
Tim hawa he's earned 19 out of a
possible 20 Gore meal points but how it
does see one major problem here
restaurant patrons in the German capital
can be a little on the stingy side
diners in Berlin aren't prepared to pay
the same as they would in Munich Paris
London or Rome that's what our top chefs
are up against when they're preparing
world-class cuisine curtis pitts
incursion army took hems and haws as
restaurateurs respond to diners needs
small establishments have emerged with
specific concepts a Jewish eatery Reuben
and Carla specializes in meat dishes
like pastrami and tali oughtta and the
pollies are located in a former school
building is the place for roasts and
other traditional fare Berlin a gourmet
metropolis
Oh